las vegas mayor john lee giving the city  state of the city address today  and he delivered that speech virtually  2021 is going to be a great year  we have great expectations for the city  of north las vegas  because of what we've already put in  place  no doubt there will be challenges but  we're moving forward  mayor lee said the city has been a model  for its response to the covid pandemic  especially when it came to spending  federal funds efficiently  additionally three new industrial parks  are planned and the mayor added that  there will be more jobs to north las  vegas  city leaders also highlighting their  launch of the southern nevada urban  micro academy  as well as a renovated fire station to  operate as the harbor  which serves families in need another  economic milestone the southern nevada  water authority's decision to develop 18  miles of  new water line and 40 miles of sewage  infrastructure